adventure photographer chris burkhart is
an expert in photographing surfers
riding the coldest most punishing waves
on the planet
he's accustomed to battling the elements
in his work but one storm in iceland
nearly broke him
it was like armageddon we had basically
just been you know totally beaten to
shreds i mean it was total darkness
the storm canceled burkhard's expedition
but the decision to stay in iceland
resulted in a once-in-a-lifetime
photographic opportunity that he never
expected dude this is it this is it
right here
he managed to capture an epic adventure
under the greatest light show on earth
if you look at the northern lights and
you don't question your place in the
world
then there's something dead inside you i
can't believe that is heaven
i grew up kind of frolicking along the
coast here in central california i would
drive up the coast and try to surf with
my friends and these remote little
beaches and stuff and to be honest like
that really set the president for me
that like i wanted to just go explore
i first picked up a camera
right around the age of i think 18 19.
i realized this was it this was like the
perfect medium for expression like this
was as good as it could get
when i grew up i didn't have a passport
never traveled internationally and as i
realized that photography could be this
tool to see the world i was like oh my
gosh like this this is it this could be
my ticket
after years of photographing in stunning
beach towns around the world
burkhard decided to shift his focus to
colder climates
i had the dream job and then i realized
that i want to document places that
might not be around forever i want to
share the experience of of the
importance of seeing these places
because i want people to know that these
places are out there
there's been a lot of zero degree days a
lot of days where you're standing on the
beach or shooting somewhere on a
mountainside and you're just your organs
are hurting because it's so cold and
you're touching metal equipment and your
hands are just getting brittle and
cracked
it's type two fun you know you look back
and you you chuckle but in the moment
it's pretty brutal you want to be
somewhere else
my work has taken me to some of the
harshest environments on the planet and
i seek out some of the last places on
earth where you can really find these
raw environments
[Music]
of all the places he's been
one trip to iceland pushed him closest
to his breaking point
what started off as a trip to photograph
epic waves
became an epic battle with the elements
this last winter during the darkest and
coldest time of year we set out to
iceland
i didn't really have any idea of how it
would go
there was this one location
in this remote national park that i
wanted to go access
all i knew is that there was a boat
captain that was willing to take us
there
we finally made it to that remote bay
this national park
we're sitting there in the boat and
we're looking at this this wave
it was everything we had hoped for the
captain came out and said that the
largest storm in 25 years was coming
right now and we literally had to turn
and hightail out of there
back to the harbor
the weather changed like that and it was
like armageddon people were just like
getting food storage and stocking up
all the flights were grounded so we made
this decision that we were going to
drive 11 hours to the next safe town so
we don't come home empty-handed we were
all just defeated but still knew there
was like something else out there for us
and we just knew that we wanted to play
it out
that was probably not the smartest call
when we weren't what we originally
planned we were like forced to stay a
little bit longer and after that storm
subsided we realized that with that
storm brought incredible surf and not
only that but the northern lights are
out if the weather could just hold off
for that much longer this would be
something that would be in history books
[Music]
i convinced one of the guys to go out
the hardest thing was just keeping my
focus what i was seeing you know was
these
amazing patterns of blue and orange and
red
and green you know trickling the sky
this is maybe one of the most insane
things i've ever seen in my life
so every so often i'd get lost just
staring at the sky and somebody would
holler and i would look and see them and
i'd be like okay okay here it is
there we go ben someone's going you're
just shivering you're sitting there
you're kind of like basically going
through all the emotions but for me
anything worth pursuing is going to
require you to suffer a little bit
oh i did it
i can't believe
that i actually got you to go out there
through all that we came away with this
experience that was actually far better
than anything we could have ever planned
for
it changed everything i thought about
what was possible
i aim nothing more than to simply just
document the beauty of the world
if a photograph that somebody sees is
powerful enough to make them go
somewhere they've never been
be outside of their comfort zone spend
their time that's what i speak to is
like how we can do that more
i guess we want to just inspire future
generations to be willing to thrust
themselves into situations like that be
willing to go when everything else says
not to
even when all the odds are stacked
against you you can still create
something beautiful
[Music]
you